i feel like i get a lot of religious
vibes for you you don't seem like a sort
of person who'd be like agnostic atheist
and i'm kind of like you give me a lot
of uh religious energy as well
wow okay
what makes someone stand out in a crowd
how does someone's appearance contribute
to our perceptions about them and how do
our stereotypes influence those
perceptions today we brought a frat bro
in to play a human guessing game his
objective to find individual blonde
women in a group of 15 blonde women
using the clues we provide
can he find one of a kind
hello my name is chris and welcome to
one of a kind today we've got a guesser
and that is our man nicholas
he is a
frapra
and our contestants happy to be here
yeah can i get some thumbs up
you love to see it very nice within this
group of 15 lovely individuals there is
one hidden mystery person i will aid you
by providing you various clues along the
way and it is your job to eliminate
whoever you can to gather who the
individual mystery person is are you
ready yes okay nice
our first clue is
i danced competitively for 10
years do you dance at all nah i'm
terrible if i'm at the club i'm just
kind of like
yeah this is like so many like different
shapes and sizes look like dances and
stuff so i'm thinking like who seems
like they're very flexible
they could like i don't know bust a move
on dance floor you kind of look like the
sort of dancer type you know you ever
hear you definitely look like you can't
do some sort of ballet and stuff like
that girl in the back right kind of
comes off like a surfer straight up with
the whole necklace get up i don't know i
feel like if there's a venn diagram of
surfers and dancers they're two separate
circles so like
[Music]
i don't know why but i am so sorry i
think you might not be a dancer i don't
know i don't know what it is about it
yeah sometimes the vibe just don't be
hidden yeah i'm just going off of vibes
right now because i really do not know
what like a dancer looks like for the
two of you lovely individuals you may
exit the stage sorry i hope you're
terrible at dancing i guess
clue two
i have never been in a sorority
oh wow do you consider yourself to be a
stereotypical frat guy not at all not at
all would you say like you have a
stereotype of what you think a sorority
girl is i'm going off of
movies like i don't know neighbors
with zac efron and you've got like
everywhere like selena gomez and stuff
like that thinks about a lot about their
like health and body and exercise and
stuff like that so that they come off
like really well do you have anybody who
you're leaning towards elimination wise
i'd say you make up is i don't say on
fleek but it's popping you know accurate
yeah so we've got one sorority girl
who's the second i feel like you were in
a sorority back in the day yeah yeah i
think you were in a sorority gotcha okay
one and beautiful thank you for your
time we'll see you guys later thank you
you ready for the next clue yeah i'm
ready for the next clue let's do it
clue number three
people often tell me my appearance is
similar to a young taylor swift you're
talking like country music tea drops
exactly yeah she was in that flowy dress
and she was just like
yes i think i feel like you don't really
look too much like a young taylor swift
it's probably the flat hair that's doing
it for me and who else wouldn't if you'd
like any of them to do something
interesting you're more than welcome
please you feel free
yes i would love to see your hair clear
okay first off i kind of want to see you
do a hair flip at the back oh hello
that's definitely a taylor swift look
right now oh
well executed yes that's tea drops on my
guitar right there
how about you in the front could you do
a quick hair flip for me
how about uh in the second row oh it was
in the little ponytail
i don't know that's a little bit too
less of a taylor swift for me i'm sorry
but i don't have to eliminate the two of
you okay both of you can exit the stage
thank you
clue number four when i go out with my
friends i'm the mom of the friend group
you're the mom of the friend group what
role do you play in your friend group oh
i'm the one that's always on the ground
at like 11 p.m i go hard i go fast
on the floor on my ass so this person
would be the one like i got you yeah i
feel like
you give me a lot of like hey i'd take
care of my friends vibes if a creepy
dude pulls up to my friend you just be
like
nah you also give a lot of mom energy
it's a weird statement to say maybe also
look for somebody who has a similar i'm
also on the floor at 11 pm but i feel
like you've got chaotic energy yeah
you've got a lot of chaotic energy
yeah
here we go
oh wait hang on i can see that smile you
you look you look like you have a good
time at the party yeah no no i'm locking
uh you as well as the girl
right there
can you always exit the stage please
thank you i'll see you later's going on
let me know okay
clue number five i am an agnostic
atheist agnostic atheist are you
religious uh roman catholic filipinos
growing up were very yeah very big on
that stuff i feel like i get a lot of
religious vibes for you you don't seem
like a sort of person who'd be like
agnostic atheist and now i'm kind of
like peeking over at the necklaces now
like a cross sword yeah nice that's a
good go too i feel like you give me a
lot of religious energy as well
wow okay
i would like to lock you in as well okay
okay you may leave the stage friends
we'll see you next time
oh
okay we're down to our final five does
it still feel like the mystery person is
in our midst i sure hope so okay be
embarrassing if it comes left on the
first round clue number six i'm
passionate and determined
about maintaining my 4.0
gpa i'm going to give that a little mini
round of applause yeah
that's very nice so someone who's the
mum of the group as well as someone who
is happy with their academics what kind
of student were you oh i graduated with
a 4.0 as well so i'm trying now so i'm
trying to see who were the nerds with me
yeah i feel like you
are like someone who would sit with me
at the library and just be like okay
yeah we gotta we gotta get to our books
and i mean the girl on the back still
has the taylor swift vibe as well so i'm
i'm keeping a bookmark on the two of you
right now nice nice nice yeah when i
think like someone who's getting like a
4.0 i'm gonna flip down on the head and
see who's the person who likes the party
i feel like you love the party
look at those nails man
i love it i love those nails i'm going
off of the nails right now okay okay all
right oh hello
oh man now you showed me
okay maybe i shouldn't have gone off the
nails technique okay all right we'll see
let's see
i don't know i feel like i've got a vibe
from you look at that hair
she's ready to go out of town so i think
i would like to lock in you and you all
right
you can leave the stage thank you guys
clue seven i went skydiving last week
and i want to go again oh
so we got a little thrill seeker a
little bit of a thrill seeker it is said
that bonds have more fun that said for
this round we are going to only
eliminate one person i feel like you
seem like the sort of person who would
just keep on getting going skydiving
over and over again jumping out of
planes is just your version of fun okay
can you pretend like you just jumped out
of a plane and you're just like
free-falling for a good solid minute
yeah come on
i wouldn't be giggling if i was
i'd be scared for my life i'd be like oh
god the floor's on the floor
a thrill seeker might giggle that's true
that's true but can i see your version
yeah
yeah okay i can see the form yeah her
arms are wired out yeah yeah yeah yeah
there's familiarity i'm sorry but the
giggles a little bit
i feel like it's a giveaway but i feel
like i'm totally wrong with this you can
step off the stage thank you all right
for this clue it's gonna be a little bit
different than the last clues the clue
that i'm gonna give you now is actually
an audio clip hey my name is gemma and i
love to party as much as the next person
but sometimes i just need to lie in my
bed and do nothing to recharge
gemma all right who looks like a gemma i
don't know why but you seem like a gemma
that didn't work
gemma no okay
i don't know why but i feel like you're
going to be the gemma who likes to party
and sometimes lie in bed all right yeah
that means our individual on the right
hand side is not gemma and we can lock
her in for elimination i'ma lock it in
okay i'm gonna lock it in exit the stage
thank you for your time and energy we'll
see you later nicholas this is the
person you've deduced to be the mystery
person
on three
you will say hi my name is
and we will find out if this is indeed
gemma or not
are you ready for the moment of truth
long time coming let's do it here we go
three
two
one
hi my name is malia
are you disappointed yeah
that was rough yeah indeed indeed how do
you feel pretty good you think i look
like taylor swift you think i'm smart
you think i'm a mom
i'm not any of those so yeah i know i
don't know it's okay okay all right guys
come on bring it on back
hello welcome back
[Music]
all right ready now i'm ready let's get
it three
two
one
my goodness that means our individual on
the right hand side is not gemma
i'm a lucky thing okay
clearly my hair whip was not good enough
i was dotting myself with the whole
taylor swift situation
i should have gone with my first gut
choice hey how does it feel how does it
feel to know this is terrible
you were this close what was this course
if it were an exam you'd get like 98.
but then she got the hundreds
you guys should go skydiving
sounds like a plan you want to go
skydiving tomorrow i've been trying dude
i'll go with don't do it just do it yeah
man i was i was bummed and then
especially with the reveal when i was
this close it was it was rough the
taylor swift one was probably the one
that i'm going to get chewed out on a
lot because she does look like an early
taylor swift the taylor swift thing i
was like i don't really see it some
people see it though i think your hair
color describes you but like it doesn't
define who you are as a person he looked
at me and he said you definitely get
good grades and i don't
be
eliminated for not being the mom friend
when i'm a nanny for three kids was
funny i was eliminated because
apparently i look very religious but my
family is actually from the soviet union
i've never been around religion in my
entire life i've had pink hair and i've
been brunette and i've been blonde and i
definitely see a difference in the way
people treat me any time that i've met
someone when i'm blonde i hear a lot
that i was really intimidated by you
when i first met you but that never
happened when i had pink hair or when i
was brunette it's very interesting
thanks so much for watching by the way
if you need to forcefully remind some
people in your life to be kind make sure
to visit
shop.jubileemedia.com and with that
we'll catch you guys next time and that
is our game today so thank you to you
guys and to all of our contestants
good job
[Music]
[Applause]
wow oh my god